welcome back to new rock stars despite
all the many surprise cameos spider-man
no way home was one major marvel cameo
actually removed from this film that
might have made toby and andrew's
arrivals a bit more monumentous than
just medley's accent
[Music]
this is rogue theory folks we are back
in 2022 is this technically the third
season of rogue theory is that where
we're drawing the line this is a show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles we love and right now
that biggest nerdy title is spider-man
no way home i'm here with three of my
favorite nerds i'm eric voss going rogue
with me today is the always amazing
jessica clemens
right back to you and swinging in from
the twitch verse it's angelica trey
hi it's good to be back hi everybody uh
hi i love your uh background it's so
dreamy and starry and um i'm gonna catch
some of those falling stars put it in my
pocket i'd love it um but also
from his own glorious background look at
that lighting my god sorcerer supreme
hosted the film philosophers podcast
it's eddie villanueva what is up guys
it's good to be back good to be in the
new year spending it with some good
old-fashioned nerds and uh yeah let's
get into this
we are some old-fashioned nerds we are
for sure we are a couple spider-man
noirs here but we have some modern
sensibilities as we read variety
that's one of the old traits but anyway
variety reported this week for in an
interview with the uh no way home
screenwriters that originally the tobey
maguire and andrew garfield variants of
peter parker were actually going to be
brought in by a completely different
process
a different marvel character not by
ned's accidental magic so i'm going to
just read what variety wrote here they
they said at first they had planned a
very different introduction for mcguire
and garfield's peters they arrived just
after the death of peter's aunt may more
on that in a bit but not by happenstance
quote they are brought in by a marvel
character going
here are the saving graces and they are
going to help you through this according
to chris mckenna though he declines to
say which character it was it was just
more of a deus ex machina now for those
of you who aren't up to date on your
greek drama terms day6 machina
translates to god from the machine if
you watch matrix resurrections you'd be
an expert in this uh his company's named
uh
but uh it means god from the machine uh
it's how they would use you know cranes
to lower in gods from the heavens to
rescue characters from their uh crises
and really it just refers to any time
you bring in a late in the story
character just from above to rescue
characters through some random
inexplicable means in toy story three
they had like a fun nod to this where
the the claw
came back and literally rescued them as
a day6 machina um but here they're
referring to it as there's some mystery
marvel character from the heaven some
kind of godly spirit who uh just
recognizes peter's pain and says i know
of the best people from the spider-verse
who can help you get through this so i
want to ask you guys who this marvel
cameo could be why was he so uh cagey
about who this character would be let's
run through some options together um so
i want to start with the idea of could
this just have been doctor strange he
spent this whole part of the movie
strung up in the grand canyon in the
mirror dimension but was he originally
going to play a bigger role in the uh in
the second and third act of this movie
could he have been the character who uh
helped out peter here so really quick
we're assuming that the entire second
and third act changed so he's not upset
about there being more people in the
world because i guess in this situation
he probably wouldn't
welcome the other two peters to console
him because he'd be like we need to send
them back i know your mom just died but
i need to send them back so we're
assuming that or like you recognize that
the mess has already happened and he's
like well now that these guys already
here maybe they can help you in ways
that i can or a possibility of it being
an out of time
you know stephen strange kind of like
the
the [ __ ] stephen strange in another
time frame or something strange
and coming in and saying i've seen how
this plays out let me help you here
i like that idea a lot eddie yeah we saw
in the multiverse of madness teaser that
there totally is going to be multiple
stephen strange's uh that he comes into
contact with in that movie maybe they
could have already started to introduce
that here maybe in this movie we think
it's just doctor strange but at the end
of it it's gonna be revealed actually
that wasn't me i was strung up here the
whole time so if i was here who was
there old man strange and they pull up a
mask and then scooby-doo this [ __ ] comes
back out but yeah
good theory good thing i like that one
because yeah doctor strange just seemed
so stubborn in no way home that the only
plausible explanation if it was strange
is it's a different strange
yeah
yeah like to me the most telling part of
this uh variety interview is that like
they they're reluctant to say who it was
like if it was just something as simple
as like we want something different to
happen with doctor strange so it means
like if it was doctor strange or whoever
it was it means that there's some
upcoming title that these two writers
don't want to reveal anything to yet
that there's some kind of plot thread
100 marvel so it could be doctor strange
but let's bring up the co-star of
multiverse of madness scarlet witch as
an option someone who understands grief
probably better than anyone in the
marvel universe at the moment i would
believe that one
i believe that one more so especially
because and we talked about this on
monday that uh i was like scarlet witch
has so much remorse i think still now
that she's like hiding she still feels
bad about what she's done and she
recognizes what she's done that i
wouldn't but i still think she would be
willing to emotionally be there for
someone else even i meant breaking a
little bit of the like law so i think
she would definitely have brought like
been like you'll be okay
this is like this is who and he knows
who she is so it's not like it's new but
i feel like that could be someone that
could have came out of hiding and helped
him find himself after that death
because she knows death so i that's the
one i'm standing with
hmm i mean imagine that cameo right
there like probably wouldn't be through
a sparkle portal she would just like be
a voice from the shadows or just like
her her uh her hand like her uh black uh
colored hand would just like uh land on
peter's shoulder and be like what the
hell and then uh kind of like the way he
reacted to strange in the dungeon and
instead you turn around and it's
elizabeth olsen want to max them off i
mean that would have been i would have
stood up and started screaming in the
theater if she yeah in this movie that
way or anyway right yeah oh man i i
would definitely
i would definitely see that with her
level of empathy too where she would
probably hear out
tom holland's spider-man and say you
know what i like this redemption arc i
will help you out
let me help you with the storyline let
me help you with that yeah yeah let's
further this along let's unbox it let's
get you more movies let's get you more
money let's get you more movies
uh yeah i like that idea okay eddie oh
sorry i just i i like that i like the
idea that wanda max muff is finally
coming into her own as her
impact as a character throughout the
entire
marvel comic universe that we're finally
seeing her get to the stage where she is
on equal footing so it'd be really great
it would have been really great to have
wanda in there especially to set up
multiverse of madness
yeah thematically i think we're all
realizing that this is exactly what
wanda's been trying to do right we saw
her at the end of one division flipping
through the dark hold we assumed trying
to find her kids somewhere in the
multiverse and if that is what her
objective was in that moment that's
exactly what she would want to do for
peter here now we don't know how much
she knows peter parker they were
fighting in the same battle in avengers
end game but yeah i don't think they've
ever said any words to each other but at
this point she has to be aware of him
civil war civil war right in the battle
scene oh that's right they they did
fight in that battle it was quick but
yeah it was kind of like uh he's this
dope swinging over here i'm gonna fight
these guys over here i don't know if
they've ever i'm i'm blanking right now
i don't think they've ever actually
talked to each other but these are two
characters i gotta see talk to each
other sometime soon you know
that would be great if she kind of takes
over that parenting mother role that
aunt may left you know with him like
she's just like he's a young boy he
reminds me of my son
my invisible son and he's like she
should adopt peter parker and ned and mj
like i lost billy toby but you'll be my
children
i would cry in theaters if she even got
like if she was like i had a son like
you once i'd be like oh
i'll be like no
over to wanda's house they're like i
don't trust this lady
throw her in an oven
that would be interesting as well like
in the in the in the kind of sisterly
vibe she says you know i had a brother
who was just like you oh yeah and then
going that route seeing as you know
currently with you know uh that would be
an interesting take as well if they do
create that kind of familial kind of
vibe
yeah i think that's a huge theme with
wanda right is family and
then the grief of that and so i
definitely think she's willing to go
through
any lengths in order to
have someone that feels like family or
bring back a family so yeah i can see
that she comes out i don't go friends
i've got family
[Laughter]
and then it's too fast too furious there
you go
she's speeding in that ferrari i'm
trying to keep it i'm trying to keep it
within the wizard family for now right
now um
wong is someone who left early on in the
story and wong is the sorcerer supreme
could he have been someone who helped
out peter parker in this moment because
as we saw in the movie he did not
deny strange the opportunity to do this
spell he just said lead me out of it and
then he disappeared from the rest of the
movie would it have been interesting if
this sorcerer supreme wong could have uh
brought over these peter parkers to help
tom in this moment i think wang was so
fleeting in the film
but it would be really funny if he just
popped out of a portal and went fine
i'll help you out and then like just
went back in and just started doing his
stuff you know like going back to it
that would be really silly and honestly
i could see him doing that type of thing
just because his character is so serious
but he does some really funny stuff
do we see him return or is it supposed
to jump to the shang chi part where he
goes and gets
do you know what i'm talking about
because at the end of shanghai
i think takes place before no way home
um like i i think chung chi takes place
over the summer time it does it does
sorry yeah he's going to the okay got it
he's just a busy sorcerer he's he's
running around yeah he said
the guy's everywhere i just want to know
if wong could have had some relationship
with ned's nana you know like ned
supposedly threw his family lineage had
some magic which that's one of my gripes
with this movie is it does change the
way magic is supposed to work in the mcu
it's supposed to be like you go to
kamartage you just train for months and
months and years and years and
eventually get it strange was able to
expedite that because he has the
photographic memories he studies at
night time but like the fact that ned
just threw his like harry potter
bloodline or whatever could could
suddenly do magic that's not how magic
is supposed to work
that you can train at for a long long
time well maybe that means
oh no sorry i was like maybe that gives
reason to why he's so important like ned
has to be like the one of the most
important people now in the franchise
the fact that it's just in him
well i think that's an opportunity there
like where ned since the multiverse is
ripped open he mentioned in the in the
movie are there other ned leeds is out
there could ned through some other
timeline been brought up as a sorcerer
for years and years and years and now
that the the rift has opened up he is
now connecting with that person's magic
and the way that peter parker
seems to have an elevated spidey sense
because other peters are in the universe
right now this is kind of like a
convergence event and ned as a sorcerer
in another timeline is now like tapping
into that so he doesn't need to this ned
he still kind of sucks at it but it has
an ability to open up portals just on
the world level
yeah because that opens up so many
possibilities within other
multiversal you know versions of the
same character too yeah that's uh yeah
could this create x-men
yes the answer to that question is
always yeah i said every video yeah you
do it new rock stars could this bring
the x-men yes the answer is yes they
already exist i want to see x-men as bad
as you eric i'm like bring america and
that's that's kind of my my mindset in
terms of
also thinking about how these two got
into this particular situation and i
mean what if what if that particular
you know very well-spoken person who
said that line was you know professor
xavier like what if there was a way
where that was a possibility and uh you
don't actually see him because he's
floating on his wheelchair and then he
just poof goes away into the next
multiverse because we know that that's
also a part of the x-men storyline and
professor xavier has his hand as well as
you know magneto in different timelines
and so forth so that would be an
interesting intro into that that's fun
that would
i i mean absolutely every time a portal
opens in the mcu part of me dies when
it's not one of the x-men you know true
like oh please could it just be
professor xavier it would force uh
xavier to be an expert in the multiverse
which when we left ian mckellen uh and
patrick stewart those guys didn't know
[ __ ] about any multiverse they knew
about time travel from days of future
past but like
unless we introduce a new um uh
professor x right if we recast them have
a new professor x and this guy's also a
multiverse expert i feel like
someone one of these fox property
characters who will be
a sudden multiverse expert i think all
of us who have no trouble buying would
be uh uh reed richards right so if reed
richards comes in this guy probably
knows more about multiverse science than
than most characters who they bring in
um so but i think you're onto something
there i i hope we see that multiverse of
madness at least you know
i want to ask you guys is there a chance
that
you know still trying to keep in the
wizard family for now
the ancient one we saw the ancient one
come back in what if right and was kind
of this ghostly presence uh from across
timelines could the ancient one is a
ghost someone who also knows quite a bit
about grief and quite a bit about moving
on from death as she was able to to
teach to strange in my favorite scene in
the doctor strange film could her uh
spectral presence have been the one to
introduce uh tom holland peter to his
other variants i think on may dying is
his absolute point i don't think him
meeting the other variants of himself is
so i don't think that ancient one would
have came back because it's not like may
dying was like a needed a needed point
all of them have their all of them have
someone that dies so i think she's like
unless aunt may survived i think that
would bring the ancient one back to be
like she's gotta die but um i don't
think
involving the other two parkers was even
a part she's like everyone die like you
don't need to see them like you just
need this person to die so i don't think
so
that's that's a really good point in
terms of that absolute
uh point that you know the ancient one
speaks about in in the what if series uh
giving a whole new kind of mindset
towards all those big moments in comic
book history as well as mcu history you
know what are some of those absolute
points throughout the last
20 plus films that we've been seeing
and seeing if there's some kind of
mysticism behind the scenes of what's
going on so that happens
so i really i really do agree i think
the fact of the matter is that her
appearance would have probably been more
to enforce that absolute point as
opposed to giving
comfort after the fact
sure giving comfort she doesn't know
comfort she doesn't know comfort
[Laughter]
yeah well plus we have a tendency with
these you know very wise characters to
trust the process right so we saw a lot
of that with what if and and the watcher
so i could totally see that
unless the watcher somehow intervened
like in this alternate um i don't know
movie line i don't i don't know if
that's that would be kind of it would be
that would be cool yeah let there be
peters yeah the fact the way he ended uh
what if how he suddenly just let natasha
romanov transfer timelines like the guy
is clearly like ah i'm not supposed to
intervene but this is a pretty huge
intervention yeah he let her do that i
feel like he would be totally okay with
peter's meeting under peters all right
um but let's look at uh this is still a
sony movie right and we had that huge
moment where we saw all these sony verse
characters appear in the purple riffs
and uh in the video that we released
earlier this week i pointed out how one
very much looks like a seated madame
webb
madame webb seems like the ideal
badass cameo who would introduce peter
peters that's her whole thing she's like
meet all the peters it knew you're
stronger together so could this have
been the psychic mutant madame webb and
then at some point sony and marvel were
like you can't put her in this movie yet
yeah they're they they would be like
that's too crazy because i was about to
be like this she's a mutant so that
would be our introduction it's through
magical
that's true that's true that's true
that's true
then yeah that'd be fun but that'd be so
much to add into there our very new
character that everybody would be pretty
this is a completely new character uh
but she's cool i'm very into i mean
imagine helen mirren madame webb we'd
all lose our freaking minds oh my god
i'd like helen mirren
that would be the best thing ever yeah
yeah that would be really cool but i
don't know um just what jessica said
they threw in so many new
characters into the tom holland verse
that yeah i think it might have been a
little overwhelming though would have
been cool
yeah
i mean post credit scene
post credit scene that's uh you just
shove all your weird [ __ ] in the post
credit scene yeah fine with it yeah
they're like here's a new character
here's honestly sometimes i'm just
paying to go see the post credit scene i
am literally just like yeah i care about
the movie but i care more about that
i mean that's a business model for like
90 of the mcu right yeah yeah
the credits start rolling you're like
all right now's my time you actually
talked about yeah i was like now to
finally eat my hot dog
the coldest hot dog
speaking of wizardry and magic and so
forth and and still on that because one
of the things that really got me from
that article was like i said that the
very well spoken uh
you know spokenness of that individual
and another person that we know of that
speaks very well that just had a really
great stint in his own series what if
the possibility that the two peters were
brought in by loki
um during the course of everything going
on he does have the ability to travel
through different timelines
and maybe at some point in time he's
gotten to a point where he's able to
help
you know more as
you know somebody who has access to that
and brought those two in
peter i was thinking about that eddie
with the tva's work i was like what if
they were trying to like bring in the
tva slightly in no way home and that was
the way to do it was through loki yeah
but then i don't know but i would love
it no i mean
i think you're you're totally right like
either either loki or sylvie or i mean
think of this way kang like kang comes
in he's like hey you need some help and
then but it's really he's got like some
mischievous intentions behind that the
only issue with that is recently there
was an interview this week where the
screen artists are like yeah uh no way
home was pretty locked in before that
loki finale happened we had no idea that
was happening but like our head cannons
can make this church exactly eddie jeffy
you and i just or we could just hear
like wow
and then you know the peter's coming
dude
it's just moments
look at the peters wow
[Laughter]
um this has been a rich fascinating
conversation exactly the conversation i
want to have on the first rogue theory
of the new year so here's what i'm gonna
do um let's see
jessica you had some great thoughts here
uh i'm gonna give you two rogies
uh i love your takes there
um uh angelica i'm gonna give you one
arogi you had some great takes as well
but eddie i think uh overall you
probably had a couple really amazing
takes there the idea of uh
not only the tva possibly coming in but
uh charles xavier coming in and
ultimately the first ad first of the gay
this idea of being an alternate strange
i mean i think that if i had to say like
these screenwriters
what they the toys they had in their toy
box who they most likely i think a
strange missing from the second act of
this movie is probably if you're going
to have some harmony and some balance in
your movie i think you'd want strange to
be in that second act there um but all
these are uh awesome ideas and i want to
talk more about the spider verse going
forward specifically with the news this
week that morbius the jared leto living
vampire movie was delayed uh and we have
a lot of questions about what the hell
is going on in that movie uh before we
get to those of course we have a new
latest obsession shirt inspired by the
book of boba fett available at
newrockstarsmerch.com it has an awesome
design comes in three colors officially
the best shirt to wear while climbing
out of a sarlacc pit find those shirts
and all of our great merch options in
new rockstarsmerch.com and we have some
sponsors we want to thank this episode
thank you sunbasket for sponsoring us
old habits die hard so if you're looking
to kick off the year with new healthy
eating habits you can get a quick start
with sunbasket meals sunbasket delivers
the joy of eating with bold flavors
organic produce and sustainable seafood
and meats their award-winning chefs are
constantly innovating with new recipes
to keep it interesting each week with
dozens of options sun baskets fresh and
ready meals are a perfect hot lunch hack
heat and eat in minutes and you can put
dinner on autopilot with easy to prep
meal kits that impress for date night or
win over the picky eaters in your family
plus they've got healthy snacks or
grab-and-go breakfast items for busy
mornings whether you eat vegetarian
paleo gluten-free or low-carb sun basket
is something to check any and every box
you can choose from delicious recipes
like pan seared salmon tikka masala over
superfood rainbow quinoa honey balsamic
glazed chicken with warm cabbage apple
salad or chipotle barbecue tofu salad
with black beans and honey mustard
vinaigrette set up weekly delivery skip
a week whenever you need to it's simply
easy and you will love it right now sun
basket is offering 90 off and a free
gift when you order go to sunbasket.com
rogue and enter promo code rogue at
checkout that's
sunbasket.comrogan at your promo code
rogue and we want to thank expressvpn
for sponsoring this episode you might
not know this but netflix has different
content available to users depending on
where they are located watching netflix
without expressvpn is like paying for a
gym membership but only being able to
use a treadmill which is the only thing
i use at the gym because i'm afraid of
the big scary things that are
complicated and i got these jack dudes
they're just staring at me like i don't
wipe the sweat off anything but i'm
gonna
usually use my sweat rag puny little
but
anyway that's why i don't do gyms but uh
those of you who do
it's like
expressvpn lets you change your online
location so you can control where you
want netflix to think you're located
they have almost 100 different server
locations so you can gain access to
thousands of new movies and shows this
works with other streaming services like
bbc iplayer youtube and more personally
i sometimes feel like i have watched all
of netflix at this point it's just
really nice to be able to click a few
buttons and boom
i have a whole new netflix to watch so
you open up the app select the location
tap one to connect and then you refresh
a page to access the geo-restricted show
that you watched expressvpn has the
added benefit of encrypting your data so
that you can browse that web securely so
be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
rogue don't forget to use our link at
expressvpn.comrogue
to get that extra three months of
expressvpn for free let's move on to
morbius the living vampire movie that
just got delayed sony announced that
they were delaying their jared leto
morbius spider-verse film from january
to april 1st reportedly as a response to
the massive success of spider-man no way
home and a hope to have another major
title in the second financial quarter of
the year since no way home is doing so
good it's like
do shareholders not understand just how
these things work like they're like oh
oh you're a successful company in the
second half of the year do are charlotte
just freaking goldfish who don't
understand that movie releases it all
just happens all money coming in
i'm sorry i hate how the financial world
works it's stupid but anyway that's
supposedly why they did it now uh we
hoped that no way home would end with a
bit of clarity as to which part of the
spider-verse morbius takes place in but
uh the movie looks like some mix of um
elements from the mcu like michael
keaton coming back as vulture as well as
the andrew garfield continuity because
we saw the oz corp tower that is the
exact same version of the tower that we
saw in the 2014 and 2012 film as well as
the uh toby maguire continuity because
we did see that graffiti of spider-man
as a murderer but it is the the rainy
era of the spider-man suit and then
there's a version of the daily bugle
that is none of these it's some crappy
poorly designed prop that i have gone
off on on twitter but i
i want to ask you guys now that we have
seen spiderman no way home we saw how
that movie ended how it supposedly reset
the universe by uh including this memory
wipe spell and no one knows that peter
parker's spider-man now
but how do you justify what we saw in no
way home with what seems to be the logic
of morbius's universe as a result of
doctor strange's multiverse spell what
is going on in morbius
dude okay hear me out thank god angelica
no no okay okay i was like you go first
absolutely um
i i don't know if this is
super duper wacky but
what if it was an oz corp bat that got
out and it was one of the bats out of
the
dozens thousands of bats that flew at
morbius and turned him
into what he is
so it's like an oscar bat
from that toby spider universe
hmm i love that theory because i guess
uh they're always trying to experiment
on those animals to get some serum to
make chris cooper less dead
exactly so he's like the spooky bat
version of spider-man
interesting you get a you get a just for
that
that's a really good theory and i don't
want to follow it so eddie you have to
can
[Music]
you guys my stove's on fire i gotta go
i gotta get up let it burn
i i have to fix this
i feel like i feel like we're gonna be
seeing like an incorporation of
um the
into the spider-verse kind of logic how
there are even though uh kingpin had all
these different things going on when he
would hit that
whatever it was the device that created
the multiverse trying to show up in him
trying to save his wife and kid
and we see remnants of it even after
that device
you know got shut down we still saw
remnants of that multiverse kind of
almost like aesthetic in certain parts
of it so what if utilizing that same
aesthetic we see glimpses throughout
morbius of you know talking about that
huge change that huge thing that
happened they'll probably put a name to
it
and talk about how you know ever since
that glitch or whatever that you know
this is there and and you know this you
know we have pictures kind of like in
that daily bugle that's in the uh
trailer
we have pictures of this spider-man but
this spider-man doesn't look like this
spider-man and and so because of the
fact that those glimpses are there and
those glitches
i feel like certain remnants and things
like that are gonna follow suit like the
designs and things like that mine's a
little bit more a little bit lower down
than angelica's but i think in terms of
like the basic logic for movies i feel
like it would be pulling from that
because it's it's a it's a winning
formula already
so i think what's tough is like would
people recognize that a glitch in the
matrix has occurred you know when they
just accept their reality as it now is i
mean we're already playing with people's
memories so like as part of that memory
reset do they just accept that there is
an oscorp tower here but there's also a
vulture here and he's always been the
vulture and we all just kind of accepted
that j jonah jameson was the same guy
you know it's like yeah oh he's just jk
simmons he's just that's always been who
jay jonah jameson is in the mcu but also
in the rainy verse
is that the logic they're going to use
for michael keaton as vulgar or they're
all experiencing the mandela effect and
they they piece it together eventually
eventually
eventually they're like ones and twos
there hey yeah
because even even in the one of the
things that i noticed especially with
jay jonah jameson since you brought that
up was in the beginning we see him doing
his his broadcast
in his garage of sorts you know half you
know in shorts and everything in green
screen and then like
just a little bit later we see him he's
got like a full-fledged studio and
everything right after the fact i don't
i don't remember if that's before or
after when the spell gets messed up but
what if that was
because he was starting making more
money trash in spider-man you know just
over the course of a couple months of
doing that you know because like that's
what happened in the summer
we jumped ahead like a few months and i
think he also has like a helicopter now
you know
but he's doing well something has
changed yeah i mean he definitely reset
when he didn't know who spider-man was
anymore so like and we know based off of
that spell it wasn't just they
lobotomized them like this was like back
to the future photo fades this was
hermione granger obliviate you know like
photos change physical [ __ ] around this
world documents changed uh videos were
scrubbed from the internet like and
people's experiences must have been
warped in a specific way that no longer
had an unmasked spider-man in them
either that spider-man and their memory
was masked or like
all of ned's memories where he was
hanging out with peter in some kind of
spider-man context were warped so that
he was either hanging out with a warped
uh he was hanging out with a masked
spider-man in those stories or he was
just sitting by himself in a room
staring at a wall playing with legos
like well that's bleak
the logic is loose
yeah loose
logic's loose but in that loose logic we
can fill in the gaps however the hell we
want that's why the true about that
is there any confirmation as to like
what part of the timeline morbius takes
place because what if all this is
happening before even
the spell gets you know taken place
possible that's possible yeah all we
know is that he knows that someone named
venom exists right and that there is a
criminal played by michael keaton who
says what's up duck you know yeah um but
like yeah i think the venom thing is a
telling thing like he enough people in
this world know who venom is for him to
make that joke
so like that's telling i think honestly
from sony's perspective this is just
they have their universe and then they
have these other movies that they share
with the mcu and i think all they know
is that there's a dividing line between
those yeah they just kind of bridge with
no way home but like i think that's why
they have oscorp tower in there it's
like hey we have our universe of things
we're still allowed to put oscorp tower
in the skyline of our universe we're
still out of reference venom we can do
this this this and this
so i think in their eyes it's all like
the garfield universe
it's the yeah the venom is part of that
as well
for some reason i immediately thought
about the cat garfield and not andrew
garfield sorry i don't know
it's a tale of the mashup we need
honestly two spideys
[Music]
so angelic well it's like the three
bears angelica's
pretty pretty spot on good we got eddie
with a grounded still good and then i'm
going to come with some bat [ __ ] [ __ ] so
literally literally
i think she's like so batman you see um
morbius he takes a poop no okay so
i think and after you said the venom
thing it kind of blows a hole in my
theory which i'm a little irritated that
you brought up because i forgot
but
what if so morbius is dark and gloomy
right we already saw the aesthetic of
what it's giving us and i really like
the spiderman graffiti and you know when
the last time you did the graffiti for
iron man what if this is homage to a
dead spider-man so i think in this
universe spider-man died and i don't
think and i also when you're thinking
spider-man's dead you kind of think
what's going to happen with the villains
that are supposed to go against
spider-man it's like would it be really
chaotic or would some people just not be
as crazy so i was thinking oscorp is
just normal oz corp in this world it's
it's like it's still doing its science
stuff it's not evil it's not whatever
it's just oscorp it's a science it's
like a science building and but the
spider-man that was in this universe is
now dead so people are just giving an
homage to that spider-man that was in
that suit and then we have the hero
anti-hero
anti-hero yeah that is morbius that's
like i am going to save people and i'm
going to save the world so i think in
this universe to try to make and piece
together what could possibly happen
and i know i always wish for spider-man
to die but i think in this universe this
spider-man is dead i don't think he
exists
and
the consistency that you have yeah
i stand yeah on brand um
he needs to die oh
no no i'm joking i'm joking he doesn't
need to die but i just think in this
universe and more abuses this this one
is dead and i think after the spell it
might have taken people back to where
they were but there was no spider-man in
this one because he's dead
i'm going to give you a rogi for
originality and um and truth to yourself
because that's an important thing in
this world it's consistently staying
true to your brand thank you yeah thank
you i don't think sony will ever ever do
that until there's like a narrative
reason but i i want that that's simpler
it does answer questions you know it's
just i think realistically when this
happens they're not going to answer any
of this
story with jared leto being a vampire
that kind of references things but has
no real internal logic with how these
things connect because like spider-man
no way home barely has logic and that
movie is very much about the logic they
have a lot of fun with the logic but the
moment you start to question it it does
start to fall apart it's just they win
us over so hard with these cameos that
we don't care and that's the magic of
the movie yeah it's very magical so i
don't care
but i feel like we might care in morbius
just a little bit just just just a
little bit um
but yes i think we did as we exhausted
this as much as we can until another
morbius trailer comes out with some
other weird cameo of andrew garfield in
it
right i think if you that's one way they
can fix the magic if you just cast
andrew garfield as spider-man in this
universe guys it'll just work and have
him deny it for about eight months yeah
yeah yeah
right just do that again you have you
have three months sony to reshoot just
just have one scene just have one scene
where andrew garfield's uh uh skateboard
in the background to kingdom come by
coldplay and we'll be fine there you go
well um we now have to move on to our uh
rogue questions guys we had a crazy
episode of the book about
this week i loved it so much and one of
my favorite parts was that they brought
in a wookie by the name of black
chrysanthe who comes from the uh darth
vader comics uh dr aphra comics he's a
big boy and he's got a whole story
behind him and they added just this
other weird little backstory where he's
like look this these are not the death
pits of durr and i'm not a sleeping
trend ocean guard which is just some
other adventure that the two of them
went on or maybe just black
chrysanthemum went on um i want to know
what embarrassing story that boba fett
was alluding to to piss off that giant
wookie in that moment what happened to
get them into those death pits that was
so humiliating to black christina that
boba fett was trying to trigger in that
moment i want you guys to just fill in
the story there what was running through
that wookie's mind okay what if there
was a situation where
they were together
and
a
black
and boba fett were maybe like drinking
or something and they ended up stumbling
out
and a guard
i don't know duped him in some way and
pushed him and he he woke up in a death
pit
with a horrible hangover
so he he was they stumbled all the way
to a new planet they had quite a binger
uh they were they were on the planet
and then they ran into a narcoleptic
trend ocean
who yeah it was pissed that you woke up
or i'm thinking sleepwalker it's not
supposed to wake up a sleepwalker he
they woke up a transocean got pissed off
and pushed them
they were conveniently on the edge of a
death pit
yes i don't know why i turned this into
a
a
just wild night out yeah i want to see
this in one of these flashbacks in
episode three i wanted to go in the back
and remember this crazy trip what about
what if similar in the same vein as
angelica they went out went out drinking
uh
you know the wookie got smashed they're
walking around outside they see a very
hairy trandojian soldier and the wookie
starts hitting on it and starts rubbing
on it and
then the the soldier gets freaked out
chases them all the way near to a you
know death pit and then
uh they end up like laughing about it
after the fact
i think i do like that but it's a
positive thing between the two of them
he's trying to say don't beat me up
friend we had this crazy night together
exactly what if like angelica and eddie
they went for a few drinks at the park
and
they were like hey he's asleep let's go
steal his ship and they steal his ship
and they drive it and drive it directly
into another building
and then when they wake up and that's
how boba fett got so good at teaching
people how to drive
right it all came full circle they did
not get far at all they maybe got like
a couple of yards because because no
great story started with water just so
we're saying yeah
no no no no they were at a bar they all
end in the water yeah and yeah
i think that you know i think there's
lizards behind it i think that lizard's
now the most powerful character in star
wars because boba's like i don't know if
that lizard is part of the dream or not
this this is like he just got freaking
uh what am i thinking of he got roofied
with a lizard i think is what happened
at the end of that episode and this
lizard
jumps from nostril to nostril on
tatooine making people do crazy stuff
and they both had this ayahuasca lizard
just kind of walk them out of the desert
boba is an old friend of this lizard he
has no idea but you know this lizard is
jumped from black or santa's nostril to
boba's nostril and made them do
really hot stuff to each other they're
just like the nastiest stuff uh so some
nostrils
new rock stars after dark here we go
we're starting
there it is
it's it's like me and you and everyone
we know they just went uh nostro to
nostril and then just like they traded
this lizard as they were
putting their nostrils to each other and
just going in and then out and then in
and out and they connected this imagery
is going to haunt my dreams nothing like
a good lizard i think it's gonna make
your dreams better i think if these are
the dreams i want you know
for once can i have like vos is like i
get though i get the point
there we go for weird lessons i get the
points there you go give yourself a
rogue
there we go
um no just kidding jessica's the winner
i like her story a lot there that was
fun
but you're all winners guys you helped
us fix morbius you helped us figure out
who that cameo was supposed to be to get
the wizard uh the wizard logic making
more sense and no way home i'm proud of
us we did it we're starting off we're
starting off right here in january 2022
we're shooting this on january 6th but
rather than starting problems that will
haunt us for a year we're giving us some
nice lizard sex streams that'll haunt us
for a year and that for that i'm
thankful
thankful for all of you i love you guys
well uh support all three of these
heroes on uh their many projects we got
jessica clements lulu underscore
clements we got angelica trey ay tray we
got uh eddie villanueva at film lost
first podcast support all of them
they're doing amazing work out there and
support us with our merch you can get
this stupid shirt at uh
newrockstarsmerch.com if i see you in
public and you're wearing that shirt i
have to give you a high five
maybe right now i'll have an m95 i'll
give you a fist bump but high five might
be too much um but
yeah in april you know maybe uh if
you've got some thoughts on our rogue
theories you can share them on our
discord if you're over 18 just support
uh new rockstars you can head on over to
the new rockstars discord server join
the conversation great way you can weigh
in and you can follow me at ea boss
follow new rock stars subscribe to new
rockstars um wherever your podcast my
brain is breaking now because i keep
thinking about that lizard uh but
you uh uh support us here on youtube i
keep saying support us you've already
supported us by sticking around this
late into a video god bless you and god
bless everyone see you next time bye
everybody god bless america
[Music]
you